[Music]
[Applause]
it's jim jackson
14-year nba vet he'll be on the call for
the hawks knicks tonight
on tnt then he's got the suns and lakers
game three tomorrow night
also on tnt jim thanks for joining us
uh your level of concern for the
clippers today
is what uh very high
damn very high you know because i
covered them all year
so it was a game earlier in the year
where the mavericks were up like 50 at
halftime
and i say well you know that's an
anomaly happens one of those games now
the clippers weren't completely healthy
but during the course of the year i mean
dallas just
even last year in the bubble it was
something about that mavericks team when
they matched up against dallas
i mean um when the mavericks match up
against clippers that kind of
gave them a little fit and you can see
it kind of showing up right now
uh you know in this early series
especially dallas winning both on the
road
but you got big games from paul george
in big games from kawhi leonard
that supporting cast is very suspect
here
you know and what's weird about it dan
is that during the course of the year
nicholas the tomb really played well
early in the year was you know luke
canar who's not playing a lot because of
matchups
in this one um serge ibaka
not being back in the fold i think hurts
a lot because that was
a big component of what they did the
clippers with their
you know dribble penetration pick and
pop if you help you can pop surge out
and he can knock in that three which
also kept the court spread
and that's not happening so you combine
that with the fact that tim hardaway
junior is playing well
prizing is back in the lineup playing
you got jalen brunson who's solid
and of course lucas is going to be luke
i mean you know what i mean luke has
been
successful against his clever team
everything is trending towards the
mavericks from a match-up perspective
but but
again you win a couple in dallas now
it's even serious but
some things have to be changed level of
concern you would have for the phoenix
suns
youth is the biggest thing even with a
chris paul
okay now you're going back to la and
they like did their job you know how you
should be said then
go in on the road you just want to get
one game whether it's the first or
second game
and you want to get make sure you got
home court advantage now
and that's something now the phoenix
suns last year in the bubble
everything was great it was isolated in
the bubble now
it's a little bit more pressure playing
on the road but i think monty williams
the way he got this team locked in even
that lakers game last night okay lakers
won it
but this thing was nip and tuck you know
it could have went in the balance of
a shot here there defensive stop phoenix
could be up too off
i just never know what i'm gonna get
from anthony davis when he's great it
feels like the lakers are great
and when he's not it doesn't feel like
they're great
do you feel that same way we want you
yeah what do you think it is
what does your gut tell you i think he
he's some
he doesn't pick his spots like
you should take over the game lebron
lebron
is able to do that but he has to pick
his spots anthony davis should be like
get me the ball
i and i said yesterday get to the free
throw line
don't be shooting fade away jumpers you
know you got jay crowder on you come on
get to the hoop make them make them make
plays
on you and then it feels like that opens
up everything else
for everybody else on the team now did
you notice at the beginning of the game
they made an emphasis
to kind of really get 80 started i mean
i really get him
now he was more aggressive yesterday you
know really looking for a shot and i do
think at times
he settles for bailing his opponent out
but how many guys in the league also do
that
i mean it's it's a kind of uh a
different mindset the easy way out is to
take a little jump shot
instead of now you know pounding and
backing somebody in now is that a fact
that
you know the spacing is not there at
times or
you know it may be a double team coming
and you're trying to avoid that i don't
know but
i know what a.d and the lakers
and i think your point is valid on this
lebron can't go
38 minutes and kind of go he just can't
i mean he's not built like that but but
he is built in the playoffs for
spurge on when he can pick when he can
go
80 has to be a guy that's constantly
going
you know and whether he's shooting or
not i think is not the point
is how aggressive is he to attracting
the defense to say
okay we're gonna have to help her do
something and then here comes
okay shot over the top or he then makes
a play to one of his teammates
if i gave you the lakers or the field in
the west who would you take
oh
damn that's a tough one right there
cause the field is tough man you know
the fear it now if donovan mitchell
being healthy
murray being healthy
i still got a hedge towards the lakers
because of lebron
you know you know if there if there's a
you tell me a match-up would you think
the lakers would
really have problems i think the
clippers match up with them will but i
don't know if they can get past
no doubt i think they match up with them
well um
but but it's something about lebron in
these situations you know
do you think you'll ever pick against
lebron
it's hard that's like asking did you
ever think you could pick against
michael
you know what i mean because you you
knew it was something there
even when they got down to portland when
they played in portland one or
they played they lost the first game to
the lakers you know back then you're
like
maybe not portland i mean the lakers
it's just like uh
there's something about michael how many
times did you have that
where you go we're we're facing a guy
and this isn't gonna
this isn't gonna go well tonight like
you you can't say it but you're thinking
it and maybe
all your teammates knew that this isn't
gonna go well
but you know what though dan here's the
thing it's not so much
the guy like you know that lucas is
going to get his
okay you know that a lebron is going to
be effective in different ways you know
back in the day mike was going to get it
what gets you is the x factors
those are the guys that end up having
like dorian finney smith in that first
game against the clippers
you game plan to leave him open yeah
okay your game plan that's your game
plan and then he makes you pay for it
yeah
okay how many times have we seen robert
orri have big games
yeah shaq and kobe are going to get
there at somewhat even if they're not as
effective
but it's always the other guys
that end up having some kind of impact
on the game
and then those are the ones that you
worry about
you know to me you faced michael you
face kobe and you face lebron
where do you rank them i said mike
number one
i mean just for the seared fact that
mike
offensively and defensively the way he
attacked in multiple positions where you
can put him and he was very efficient
now lebron is very efficient but lebron
to take breaks during the game and what
i mean by briggs is
he won't be as aggressive offensively
okay
mike was always like that kobe was like
that but kobe would take some bad shots
that time
okay so he can kind of bail you out on
something but when he got going
he got going lebron is so methodical and
think about it that lebron is so
methodical in this thing
again the mindset is like magic okay i'm
gonna beat you with this
now if i get it going from here i'm fine
now
would would mike beat you from the
three-point line back in the day
not really but free throw line he get to
his spots
and he really didn't take bad shots and
that's the difference
between now lebron doesn't take bad bad
shots but mikey was something about him
man
it was and i put now i played against a
young lebron james just preface that
i didn't play against this older one
okay when he grew
but man it was something and kobe was
something else too his mindset
you know mindset was totally different
any issues with the nets if i gave you
the nets of the field in the east
nope
that was quick no and the reason why is
because it's kind of like
golden state remember so when they had
durant when he was there with play
and step more than likely two of the
three gonna have
a good game okay and even if one is off
it's maybe they're 5 for 15 6 for 18 but
they still got 18 points you know what i
mean
and they had a they got a real i like
claxton i like joe harris
shaman if he get gets his shot going i
like bruce brown
um the question is too it's like as you
advance further
now that the three are together and i
said this before they talked about the
big three a lot dan but they didn't talk
about steve nash
having the big three in in certain
situations where now
okay what plays am i gonna be
comfortable running that they're
comfortable running because they haven't
been together
you know steve is still learning yeah
and so are they
you know just being on the floor at the
same time yeah uh we'll be watching
tonight
hawks knicks at 7 30 eastern and then
you got game three
lakers sons tomorrow night also on tnt
jim thanks for uh spending time with us
buddy
anytime dan appreciate you brother
that's uh the great jim jackson 14-year
nba vet